[Music]
[Applause]
Steve Palazzolo he is one of our
favorites you can see him he's the
co-host of Pro Football Focus NFL
podcast senior analyst and uh he you can
see more of him and follow him pff.com
the PFF app uh Steve thanks for joining
us why is scoring down in the NFL
yeah Dan I think there's a bunch of
reasons you know there's not always one
but I think first off defenses are
playing a little bit softer you know
they're kind of uh sitting back trying
to get rid of those explosive plays I
think we've seen some of the more
dependable quarterbacks just you know
hit a wall in their career whether it's
Matt Ryan Russell Wilson and then you
have offensive lines there's a few teams
that have just hit a ridiculous run of
injuries so the Rams offensive line is
the worst we've ever seen under Sean
McVay and Matthew Stafford in turn has
not been able to do anything so I think
it's this combination of defense is
playing a little bit softer teams that
have run into just ridiculous injury
issues and uh in some of the older
quarterbacks maybe just not being as
Dependable as they've been in the past
why are rushing numbers up
I think there's some of the same reasons
you know again I think defenses are
inviting the run a little bit more and
then offenses are using the quarterbacks
right if you're just looking at Rushing
numbers you're you're the quarterbacks
are involved in that so you see like
what the Bears have done with Justin
Fields over the last couple weeks in the
design running game and then as a
Scrambler uh Josh Allen with the bills
Jalen hurts and the Eagles Kyler Murray
and the Cardinals and of course Lamar I
mean he somewhat started this a couple
years ago and then you even see a team
like the Giants and Daniel Jones they've
been one of the most efficient offenses
in part because if you don't respect
Daniel Jones as a runner he'll pick up
10 to 15 yards and move the chains so I
think that's a big part of it is teams
are starting to win the the numbers game
up front by letting their quarterbacks
be a part of the Run game
I said this a few years ago in the show
that eventually somebody was going to go
counter-attack and you were going to run
the football because defenses it felt
like you were looking for uh faster guys
quicker guys you had more cover guys you
had more Edge rushers and then you were
going to have a team that was just
basically going to say you know we're
going to have Brute Force here and we're
going to try to dominate you we saw this
with the Philadelphia Eagles and
Washington commanders now all of a
sudden everybody goes well the Eagles
are susceptible uh to the Run uh now
they got the the Colts coming up and
they got the Titans they got the Packers
they're not going to be able to stop
them
um what do you make of
football going maybe a little more old
school in having this power game running
attack
yeah it's an interesting one because I
think it's I don't think it's a strategy
that teams should Chase in the off
season I you know I don't think your off
season goal should be like hey let's not
have a great quarterback we're just
going to run the ball I think you always
have to chase the passing game so to
speak but it's one of those things if
Daniel Jones is my quarterback I'm
probably not going to drop back 50 times
and just let him go so the Giants have
to adjust to what they have the
Commander's game was perfect I mean that
is like a coach's dream not only because
they ran the ball but they got like four
yards every time three three yards here
four yards there they're in third and
short the entire time and then they just
kept converting converting and it kept
the Eagles off the field it the
execution of it was perfect but it's a
really difficult thing to chase every
single week you know the Bucks like to
run the ball too but they're in second
and long all the time so then Brady ends
up throwing the ball like crazy so it's
one of those things where like the
strategy of it and then the execution of
it is different but again if you don't
have a great quarterback you do have to
get creative and maybe Lean On The Run
game just a little bit more how
sustainable is what Justin Fields is
doing
oh I think it I think him as a runner is
absolutely sustainable because again
when you're running you know a run
concept up front It's All About Numbers
Game and once the quarterback is a is a
runner and you're just you're winning
right so when you put eight in the Box
the the quarterback essentially negates
the eighth person in the box and and now
I get I think we get to see Fields
develop more as a passer he's still not
there yet but it gives him time to
develop as a pastor because he's such a
dynamic Runner yeah I just wonder about
that that sometimes you'll fall in love
with what people expect you to do you
know Brett Favre loved to take chances
you know Mahomes degree of difficulty
you know sometimes you get caught up in
there yeah this is what people expect
out of me Josh Allen sometimes gets into
this and I wonder if Justin Fields goes
this is what I'm known for if I only
rush for 62 yards people are going to go
what's wrong with you
it's a good point and you know it's on
the Bears coaching staff to say look
Justin this is going to open things up I
think one of the things that's made
Lamar Jackson so successful Lamar is
still not the more most accurate
quarterback in the NFL but he completes
a high percentage of passes because of
his run threat because of his run threat
defenses are gonna you know account for
the run and the play action game is that
much more effective for a team like the
Ravens there's just more open throws
Fields I call kamet the tight end for
the Bears is all of a sudden this
monster threat he's just running wide
open through the secondary because of
all the misdirection in the play action
so Fields needs to embrace that his run
threat is going to also open up the pass
game create some easier throw I know
that you guys grade every team and you
look at every play let's look at the
Packers here what did you see that they
did against the Cowboys that could be
sustainable for the second half of the
season
it's tough to say that Christian Watson
scoring three touchdowns is sustainable
but you can at least see the explosive
plays that the Packers have I mean their
offense this year has been really hit or
miss they would they would have games
where they would just stretch teams
horizontally try to create yards after
the catch and take these low percentage
shots down the field but Watson the
second round rookie showed his speed and
when you put him inside in the slot it
actually Alters defenses you can't leave
him one on one now because you know he's
got 4-3 speed that Aaron Rodgers is
going to find so I think there is an
explosive passing attack in there the
Packers are still morphed into a run
first team these last few weeks because
of the inconsistency of their receivers
and that has set up these big plays in
the past game so I think there's an
element of Aaron Jones and AJ Dylan are
a good starting point Aaron Rodgers now
can actually create big plays because of
Christian Watson and the big playability
the speed that he brings to the table I
don't think it's going to be as
difficult for this Packers offense just
moving the chains because of the speed
element of Watson Steve paddlezolo on uh
joining us now senior analyst co-host of
Pro Football Focus the NFL podcast you
know sometimes we look at a quarterback
and he's successful because of his wide
receivers sometimes we look at wide
receivers and say they're successful
because they're quarterback how would
you assess tuatanga violoa and the
Dolphins
yeah it's always fun to try to separate
those two things I mean obviously two is
playing much better this year uh it's
it's it's not as simple as here's this
guy who played at X level and then you
add Tyree kill and he's at y right it's
not necessarily that simple but you see
what the Dolphins are doing open throws
all over the place the speed is so
evident with Tyree kill Jalen waddle
their running backs but two is executing
it what he's doing right now though is
also cutting back on the bone-headed
plays if you go back through his tape
the last couple years there's all these
random throws to safeties and just bad
plays late in the game didn't always
come back to bite but he's eliminated
those in recent weeks so I think on one
hand you have to credit the Dolphins for
putting all those weapons around him but
tuba is executing he's getting the ball
into their hands he's been accurate and
he hasn't made those boneheaded
decisions and he's always been great at
not taking negative plays not taking
those sacks even behind a rough
offensive line so I think all those
things are adding up to two are playing
at really a high level this year who's
the best wide receiver in the NFL great
wise
I'm not sure who we have the highest
graded at the moment but I would always
take Tyree kill I mean because I I don't
even our grades are really good at
capturing production I don't think our
grades can even capture what Tyree kill
does for an offense I know that the
Chiefs kind of took a step back with him
last year but man every the the the the
the need to account for Tyree kill the
the fear that he instills just if you
have to leave him one on one and the
fact that you could put Tyree kill in
the slot and give him 150 catches you
could put him outside and have him
average 20 yards per reception you can
actually let him do whatever you want
depending on what the offense calls for
so I would take Tyree kill over anybody
in the NFL Stefan Diggs Justin Jefferson
Jefferson's up there obviously I mean
the clutch plays and everything but
Tyree kill is an offense changer the
dolphins go from one of the worst
offenses to one of the best to get some
of that credit but Tyree kill is
absolutely The X Factor okay who else
would factor in there non-quarterback
who changes your offense or changes the
defense is is Nick Chubb or Derrick
Henry in that category or conversation
that Tyree kill maybe stands alone
yeah I mean Chubb and Henry definitely
changed the defense and they open things
up for the quarterback but not at the
same level again that I'm always the
pass game is just more effective than
the Run game overall so changing the Run
game a little bit yeah they do change
defenses but not at the same level as a
wide receiver I think AJ Brown in
Philadelphia you're seeing what he's
adding right just adding an X receiver
so that all the other receivers have a
little bit less pressure off them and
it's just putting the defense in a bind
AJ Brown to me was the most effective
first round pick you know the Eagles
traded for him paid him the night of the
draft and I think on the night of the
draft that was the best first round pick
everybody should want to add AJ Brown
because he does change that offense and
you can see what they've done in
Philadelphia with him any hope for the
Chargers they've got the Chiefs coming
up on Sunday night
yeah I mean we talked about offense as
being down Justin Herbert's been
throwing to third fourth and fifth
string receivers this entire season it's
it's really going to come down to health
I think with Brandon Staley and his
aggressiveness that the media loves to
either you know pick apart or praise uh
we'll see which way it goes but you know
he's going to play to win and to me it's
going to come down to those receivers
and Justin Herbert throwing the ball
down the field the guy has a cannon with
great downfield accuracy and the charges
have to tap into it and uh and try to
flip the field because Herbert's capable
of doing that have you guys looked at
college quarterbacks yet
yeah we have guys grading them all the
time
um I think it's a it's a bit of an open
you know CJ Stroud Bryce young some
people like will Levis Anthony
Richardson
um I don't know if we have a consensus
top guy just yet but we're grading every
single play of college right now but
even somebody like Drake May who's a red
shirt freshman at North Carolina
you guys he's been the best he's been
the most most valuable quarterback in
the uh in college football this year by
our numbers
he's awesome
if you had a Heisman vote
uh I might go Drake babe because I I
believe in the purity of the best player
I think Bay's been the best and most
valuable player I know most voters are
looking for Heisman moments and you know
undefeated teams and all that stuff but
I I think Drake May's been the best
player and he does have a chance to go
win the ACC Championship so maybe he can
actually get himself into that
conversation if I gave you an MVP vote
NFL
oh I'd go Patrick Mahomes I think the
fact that we see how special Tyree kills
been in Miami the fact that Mahomes has
kept that Chief's offense at such a high
level
um I know he still has Travis Kelsey but
Mahomes high volume and Grading
extremely well I think Mahomes is the
MVP right now good to talk to you as
always Steve thanks for joining us
all right thanks Dan Steve palosolum
senior analyst co-host of Pro Football
Focus NFL podcast